Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Today is day 28, I think.
What am I supposed to surrender exactly?
Well, in Romans chapter 12, we read that it talks about surrendering your
body, right? And that's great, and that's good direction.
But here's a distinction that I've found that might help you.
Some people wonder what's different about surrendering now for the purpose
of holiness versus surrendering for
salvation. Well, in salvation, you're surrendering conflict,
right? We're no longer at war. We're no longer in active rebellion against
God. But when we talk about surrendering to God as a Christian,
what are we talking about there? Because we're not in rebellion against God
anymore. What's left to surrender?
Well, if you've been following along, you probably have some idea
of the answer and where we're going.
But here's the way
I would explain it. In salvation, we surrender the bad.
In holiness, we surrender the good.
In salvation, we surrender rebellion.
In holiness, we surrender our powers.
"All my being's ransomed powers," somebody said.
In salvation, we surrender evil, but in holiness, we surrender
blessings. One songwriter said, as I mentioned a moment ago, "All
for Jesus, all for Jesus, all my being's ransomed powers."
Yes, that's what I'm talking about.
So why does all this need to be surrendered? They're not bad.
No, they're not.
But the corrupting influence of self-will
breaks down and infects everything that is intended to
be good. It does it in the world, right? Politics isn't supposed to be bad.
God instituted it for good, but it gets infected with
pride and the self sense,
and it goes bad. Same with marriage, right?
God made it as a blessing, but touched with self, it
hurts millions of people every year.
Sexuality, many other things. When we surrender these blessings,
we begin to see the problem more clearly. The problem is self.
There's a story about Jacob in the Bible, in the Old Testament.
Esau is coming, right? And Jacob's always been this self-sufficient man.
He can figure it out, and now he's up against a problem he can't solve.
So Esau's coming, and he sends ahead flocks and herds and
servants, and then he sends Leah and her kids that were not
so precious to him, and then he sends Rachel and her kids that are more
precious to him, and then he stays behind on the other side of the river
and prays. And he has to wrestle with God and
wrestle with who he is as Jacob. He has to
name the self. He has to name the deceiver.
By the way, that's what Jacob means, the one who trips others, the
one who grasps the heel.
And then
God blesses him.
In the same way, God may have you surrender many things that are in
themselves good, like Jacob's flocks and herds and servants and family.
He wants to get down to the point where he can have you
recognize that the problem isn't other
things. He wants you to see self clearly
and surrender that.
Self-will, self-sovereignty. And then he will cleanse
that self and make it wholly his and give you
self-control as the fruit of the Spirit in its
place. So that's what we surrender.
We surrender to God all that is good so that he can make
it truly a blessing by dealing with the sin
nature, the self-life that is behind it
all. And that surrender is what makes the
difference in our lives, in our lives of holiness and
purity before God.
God bless you. We'll see you tomorrow.